>> HAPPY WEDNESDAY, AMERICA.
THESE PEOPLE CAN WHISTLE.
I FEEL SO OBJECTIFIED.
IT'S GREAT TO BE BACK.
I WANT TO THANK DANA FOR
SOMETHING FOR ME WHEN I WAS OUT.
I DIDN'T EVEN HAVE TO CHANGE THE
SIZE OF THE BOOSTER SEAT.
ANYWAY.
ONCE AGAIN THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A
WARTIME PRESIDENT.
THE PROBLEM IS HE'S DECLARED WAR
NOT ON DRUGS OR POVERTY OR EVEN
PUMPKIN SPICE LATTES.
BUT ON OTHER AMERICANS.
YOU, ME, YOUR PARENTS, THOSE
FREAKS ON "FOX & FRIENDS."
BUT I GUESS THERE IS BAD AND
EVERYTHING.
>> THERE IS BAD AND EVERYTHING.
THERE'S LOUSY SENATORS, THOSE
LOUSY PRESIDENTS.
THERE IS LOUSY DOCTORS.
THERE'S LOUSY LAWYERS.
>> Greg: SOUNDS LIKE HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU KNOW MAYBE HE USED TO BE IN
THE OLD DAYS ARE PRETTY GOOD
ATHLETE.
>> I USED TO BE IN THE OLD DAYS
A PRETTY GOOD ATHLETE.
SOMEONE REALLY BIG AND TOUGH.
I WOULDN'T SCREW WITH HIM IF I
HAD A SLEDGEHAMMER.
>> Greg: SOUNDS LIKE SOMEONE
TOOK A SLEDGEHAMMER TO HIS HEAD.
HIS SENTENCES WATER MORE THAN HE
DOES.
HIS SENTENCES WANDER MORE THAN
HE DOES.
DID I GO TOO FAR?
REMEMBER WHAT USED TO BE THE
CRITICISM WHEN BIDEN WAS
RUNNING.
>> REMEMBER WHAT USED TO BE THE
CRITICISM OF BIDEN WHEN HE WAS
RUNNING.
BIDEN IS TO BIPARTISAN.
BIDEN HAS TOO MANY REPUBLICAN
FRIENDS.
NOT A JOKE.
WHAT IN GODS NAME HAS HAPPENED?
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED TO THAT?
YOU HAPPENED TO TO THAT, YOU
MUTTERING MAGOO.
YOU TOLD A BIG FIB.
WE WERE TOLD YOU WERE GOING TO
UNIFY US AFTER EVIL ORANGE GOD
GODZILLA.
THEN YOU TURNED TO AOC IN
EXTRA-LARGE DEPENDS.
THE LEAST YOU DON'T KEEP
DEMONIZING THOSE BRAVE
RIGHT-WING AMERICANS.
>> FOR THOSE BRAVE RIGHT WING
AMERICANS WHO SAY IT'S ALL ABOUT
SHAPING AMERICA AND KEEPING
AMERICA INDEPENDENT AND SAFE, IF
YOU WANT TO FIGHT AGAINST A
COUNTRY, YOU NEED AN F-15.
YOU NEED SOMETHING MORE THAN A
GUN.
I'M NOT JOKING.
THINK ABOUT IT.
THINK ABOUT THE RATIONALE WE
USE.
THIS USED TO PROVIDE THIS AND
WHO THEY ARE SHOOTING AT.
THEY ARE SHOOTING AT THESE GUYS
BEHIND ME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: HE SAYS HE'S NOT
JOKING WHICH MEANS HE'S STUPID.
BECAUSE NOTHING HE SAID SUGGESTS
HE UNDERSTANDS ANYTHING ABOUT
AMERICA.
OKAY, SUPPORTERS OF THE
SECOND AMENDMENT, GOOD LUCK
USING THAT AGAINST THE TACTICAL
FIGHTER AIRCRAFT.
SORRY, JACKASS.
SORRY, MR. PRESIDENT.
JACKASS.
WITH THAT ARGUMENT WE SHOULD
GIVE ALL OF OUR RIGHTS.
HE THINKS HE'S CLEVER.
HE IS LIKE JESSE WATTERS WHEN HE
DISCOVERS A NEW WORD.
HAVE YOU EVER NOTICED?
HE SAYS IT OVER AND OVER AGAIN
AND ALWAYS IN THE WRONG CONTEXT.
THE RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS EXISTS
WHETHER THERE ARE BOMBERS OR
NOT.
IN FACT IT'S THE
SECOND AMENDMENT THAT KEEPS US
NOT FROM BEING BOMBED BY JOE BUT
FROM BEING INVADED BY OTHER
COUNTRIES.
THERE IS NO WAY ANYONE COULD
INVADE THE UNITED STATES.
DIDN'T YOU SEE "RED DAWN?"
WE'VE GOT 400 MILLION GUNS AND
THAT'S JUST UNDER
JUDGE JEANINE'S BED.
TRUE.
DON'T BREAK INTO THAT PLACE.
BUT ONE SMALL TOWN WOULD
DECIMATE THE ENEMY AND WHY?
SECOND AMENDMENT.
SO YOU CAN HAVE YOUR F-15 BUT
IT'S ALSO OUR F-15.
IF -- AFTER WHAT THE DEMS HAVE
DONE TO OUR CITIES, BOMBING
SEEMS KIND OF REDUNDANT.
JOE IS DELIVERING ANOTHER SPEECH
TOMORROW ABOUT THE THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY WHICH MEANS THEY'VE
ALREADY STARTED DEFROSTING HIM.
BUT IF HE'S TALKING ABOUT
THREATS TO DEMOCRACY, IT'S NOT
US BUT IT'S ALSO NOT HUMAN.
THE ONLY THING HE'S A THREAT TO
IS A PAIR OF CLEAN UNDERWEAR.
BUT OBVIOUSLY IT'S HIS PARTY'S
POLICIES WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH.
WE DON'T DEMONIZE THE VOTERS.
WE ATTACKED THE POLICIES.
WE MAKE FUN OF HIM.
CRIME, INFLATION, UKRAINE, THE
BORDER, AFGHANISTAN, STUDENT
LOAN FORGIVENESS, TAXES.
THE DEMS SCREW UP ON ALL OF
THESE THINGS AND THEN DEMONIZE
YOU FOR WANTING TO REPAIR THE
DAMAGE.
IT IS LIKE JOE BEHAR BEING MAD
AT THE GUYS WHO FIX BROKEN
MIRRORS.
THIS PREDEMONIZATION AS A FORM
OF SELF-DEFENSE, LIKE SPRING
HOLY WATER AT NANCY PELOSI.
BUT THIS SHOULD BUILD YOU
BECAUSE WE WERE SOLD THE WRONG
JOE.
WE WERE EXPECTING BIDEN AND GOT
STALIN.
WHAT GIVES, JOE?
>> NO, NO, NO, I AM ALL ABOUT
UNITY.
I AM UNITY GUY.
WHAT IS THE FIRST LINE?
YOU.
YOU DO WHAT I SAY.
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS.
COME ON.
DID YOU EVER TRY TO PUT A
KEVLAR VEST ON A DEER?
THAT'S NO JOKE.
TOUGH GUY WITH A GUN.
I'VE GOT AN F-15.
TOP GUN.
I AM GOOSE.
I AM A NICE MAN.
THE ICEMAN COMETH.
GLOBAL WARMING, NO JOKE.
>> Greg: IS HE DRIVING?
REMEMBER WHEN OLD JOE TOLD
VOTERS IF YOU DON'T LIKE THEM,
YOU CAN VOTE FOR SOMEONE ELSE?
NOW THAT EVEN THE LOOSE AND ARE
CALLED FASCISTS.
THIS IDEA OF A TERROR GROUP ARE
MOMS WHO ATTEND SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS.
REMEMBER TRUMP NEVER WENT AFTER
VOTERS.
HE WENT AFTER THE PRESS.
POLITICIANS, CELEBRITIES, YOU
KNOW, REAL EVIL.
DIDN'T SEE AMERICANS AS THE
ENEMY.
JOE IS DIFFERENT.
NO SOLUTIONS ON A PARTY
PARALYZED BY WOKENESS, HE MUST
STILL FEAR AGAINST THE OTHER.
HE SAYS WE ARE MOVING TOWARDS
SEMI FASCISM WHICH SOUNDS LIKE
SEMIFLACCID, SOMETHING DR. JILL
HAS BEEN PRAYING FOR FOR THE
LAST 30 YEARS.
DISGUSTING.
DESPICABLE.
IF THE REPUBLICANS ARE
SEMIFASCIST, WHAT DOES THAT MAKE
JOE?
MEMBER THE VIOLENCE WHEN TRUMP
WON.
THE RIOTS IN D.C., JOE SAID
NOTHING.
TRUMP SUPPORTERS GETTING
ATTACKED, JOE DIDN'T SAY A
THING.
HE WRITES THAT WENT ON FOR
MONTHS, DOZENS DIED.
JOE HAD TO BE FORCED TO COME OUT
OF THE BASEMENT TO SAY
SOMETHING.
THE GOVERNMENT COERCED
CENSORSHIP OR THAT
MERRICK GARLAND DIDN'T STOP THE
ILLEGAL PROTEST OUTSIDE THE HOME
OF SUPREME COURT JUSTICES.
THE CRAP ARE BUSY MINDING ONE
SLOW DAY IN HISTORY AS PROOF
THAT 70 MILLION PEOPLE ASKED ALL
POLITICAL VIOLENCE BUT IS
APPARENTLY BEING CONSISTENTLY
VIOLENT IS PREFERABLE TO ONE DAY
THAT SUCH AN ODDITY THAT
EVERYONE CONDEMNED IT.
IF ONLY THEY WERE DEMS, THEN
KAMALA WHAT HAVE THEY HELP THEM
OUT.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
GETS ME GOING FROM 0 TO 60 WITH
THE RAYS OF HIS EYEBROW.
HAROLD FORD JR..
HE OPENS FOR COMEDIAN ROB
SCHNEIDER EXCEPT WHEN THE DOOR
IS TOO HEAVY.
ACTOR, WRITER, AND COMEDIAN
JAMIE LISSOW.
SHE HAS INTERVIEWED MORE
SWEATING MEN THEN KEVIN SPACEY.
HOST OF THE SIDELINE SANITY
PODCAST, MICHELE TAFOYA.
FINALLY, LOOK AT THAT GUY, HE
HAS WORKED MORE OVERNIGHTS THAN
A HIGH SCHOOL JANITOR.
CHIEF BREAKING NEWS
CORRESPONDENT TRACE GALLAGHER.
HAROLD, LET ME GUESS WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO SAY.
GREAT TO BE HERE.
GLAD WE HAVE YOU BACK FROM YOUR
VACATION.
I SEE THINGS DIFFERENTLY.
[LAUGHTER]
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS, RIGHT?
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS HOURS
AGO ON "THE FIVE."
IN WHICH I DESTROYED YOU.
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT IT AND
DECIDED TO AGREE WITH ME ON
EVERYTHING I SAY?
>> I HAVE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
POINT OF VIEW.
FIRST OF ALL, WELCOME BACK.
YOU ARE MISSED.
EVERYBODY ENJOYED BEING HERE.
I WATCH THIS STUFF THAT YOU HAD
ON BIDEN.
I REMEMBER, I HAVE KNOWN HIM A
LONG TIME.
MY FATHER WAS IN CONGRESS WHEN
HE WAS IN THE SENATE.
I WAS IN THE CONGRESS WHEN HE
WAS IN THE SENATE.
WE TRAVELED OVERSEAS,
AFGHANISTAN, IRAQ, PARTS OF THE
MIDDLE EAST.
HIS SON AND I WERE IN COLLEGE
TOGETHER.
THAT GUY HE'S ALWAYS BEEN IS
WHAT HE TALKED ABOUT, THE GUY
THAT WORKED ACROSS THE AISLE.
I THINK IN FAIRNESS TO HIM, WHEN
HE SAYS HE'S BEEN IN OFFICE,
THERE'S CERTAINLY BEEN A LOUD
ROAR FROM SOME IN OUR COUNTRY
WHO DON'T BELIEVE HE ACTUALLY
WON THE ELECTION.
ALLOWING LAURA FROM PROGRESSIVES
WHO RECENTLY HAD A HARD TIME
DEALING WITH THAT I THINK AT
TIMES SOMEONE ARGUE HE'S
CAPITULATED TO THEM.
BUT I WOULD ARGUE IF YOU LOOK AT
WHAT HE'S ACCOMPLISHED
LEGISLATIVELY, YOU CAN AGREE OR
DISAGREE BUT I THINK HE'S
PROBABLY TRIES HARD AS ANYONE TO
REACH OUT ACROSS VERTICALLY THE
LAST FEW PRESIDENTS WE'VE HAD.
COULD IT BE MORE?
YES.
I'VE BEEN CRITICAL OF HIM WHEN
HE'S WRONG.
I TRY TO CALL BALLS AND STRIKES
WE ARE TOGETHER ON "THE FIVE."
>> Greg: FOOTBALL ANALOGY.
>> Harold: WHEN HE GETS IT
RIGHT I TRY TO SAY IT AND WHEN
HE GETS IT WRONG I TRY TO SAY.
TO PUT ALL THE BLAME ON HIM IS A
LITTLE UNFAIR.
>> Greg: WE ARE GOING TO BE
EDITING ALL OF THAT OUT.
[LAUGHTER]
STOP IT, YOU PEOPLE.
HAROLD IS GREAT.
JAMIE, IT'S GOT TO BE HARD FOR
PEOPLE TO DEMONIZE YOU BECAUSE
NO ONE KNOWS YOU.
AND YOU LIVE IN ALASKA AND YOU
PROBABLY JUST WANT ANY ATTENTION
EVEN IF IT WAS NEGATIVE,
CORRECT?
>> Jamie: I WILL TAKE ANYTHING
AT ALL.
THANK YOU FOR EVEN COMING TO ME.
BY THE WAY, I SAW IN OUR AWESOME
ARTICLE ABOUT YOUR RATINGS LAST
MONTH.
I WANTED TO SAY I WAS SO EXCITED
WHEN I WAS READING IT, I WAS
HALF FASCIST.
THAT WAS A BIG DEAL.
YOU HAVE TO ADMIT THE BIDEN
SPEECHES ARE, IF NOTHING ELSE, A
SOURCE OF A LOT OF
ENTERTAINMENT.
MY FAVORITE THING IS TO WATCH
BIDEN SUPPORTERS BEHIND HIM WHO
DURING THE SPEECH, LAST NIGHT OR
THE OTHER NIGHT, THEY WERE
WATCHING HIM LIKE A CHILD ON A
TIGHT ROPE OVER THE
GRAND CANYON.
STAY ON THE LINE.
STAY ON THE LINE, BUDDY.
I DON'T KNOW.
SOMETIMES I DO FEEL BAD FOR HIM.
THEY SAID THAT THE HARDEST THING
ABOUT BIDEN'S WHENEVER SOMEONE
SAYS F-15, HE ELSE BINGO.
HE YELLS BINGO.
REMEMBER THAT CANCER SCARE HE
HAD?
I HEARD WHAT HE WAS AT THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE, THE DOCTOR WAS
LIKE, GOOD NEWS.
IT'S BENIGN.
HE WAS LIKE B9.
BINGO AGAIN.
>> Greg: DO YOU HAVE A THIRD
BINGO JOKE THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
SHARE?
>> Jamie: I DON'T HAVE A THIRD
BINGO JOKE.
WHAT'S IN THERE?
C4?
BINGO.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE.
THEY SAID HE WAS DOING ANOTHER
ADDRESS TOMORROW.
I DON'T THINK HE SHOULD DO
ANYMORE ADDRESSES.
I'M NOT EVEN SURE HE KNOWS HIS
OWN ADDRESS.
DROP ME OFF HERE.
ALL I REMEMBER IS IT IS A
WHITE HOUSE.
>> [LAUGHS]
>> Greg: BRUTAL.
YOU ARE SO TERRIBLE.
JAMIE.
TRACE, YOU LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU ARE KIND OF LIKE, YOU FEEL
THE CONSEQUENCES OF CERTAIN
POLICIES THAT OUR POLITICIANS
DON'T FEEL.
BUT YOU'RE ALSO ON THE NEW SITES
ARE DON'T WANT TO ASK YOU YOUR
REAL OPINION.
BUT WHAT IS YOUR REAL OPINION?
>> Trace: I HAVE A DIFFERENT
OBSERVATION AND HAROLD FORD AS
YOU MIGHT IMAGINE.
I THINK JOE BIDEN, THE TRUTH IS
HE'S ACTUALLY DE-ESCALATING HIS
RHETORIC FROM THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR.
REMEMBER WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT IN
F-15 YESTERDAY, AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE YEAR IN FEBRUARY, HE SAID
TO FIGHT THE GOVERNMENT YOU NEED
AN F-15 AND HELLFIRE MISSILES.
AND THEN BY JUNE IT WAS YOU
NEEDED F-15 AND NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
YESTERDAY IT WAS JUST AN F-15.
WE'VE COME A LONG WAY.
IT'S NOT LIKE THESE THINGS ARE
HARD TO GET.
YOU CAN GET THEM FROM THE
TALIBAN.
YOU CAN RENT AN F-15 FROM THE
TALIBAN COMPLEMENT AMERICA FOR
HUNDRED BUCKS AND THEN JUST GIVE
THEM AWAY.
AS FAR AS THE OTHER RHETORIC
WHERE HE DEMONIZES HALF THE
PUBLIC, THE LEFT AND HAROLD
WOULD DISAGREE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO ARGUE.
YOU ARE A DENIER OR HEALTH
THREAT OR EXTREMIST OR
SOMETHING.
WHAT JOE BIDEN IS DOING IS HE
VILLAIN ICE IS HALF THE PEOPLE
AND THAT SHUTS DOWN THE DEBATE.
THERE'S NO DEBATE.
THAT'S THE WAY IT IS AND --
>> Greg: SCENE.
THAT'S A PHRASE ACTORS USE.
ARE THEY APPLAUDING ME OR TRACE?
IF THEY ARE APPLAUDING TRACE,
THEY ARE GONE.
IF THEY ARE APPLAUDING ME, THEY
ARE AWESOME.
MICHELLE, ALWAYS GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
ALL I ASK FOR IS THAT FOCUS ON
THE RIGHT ISSUES AND DON'T GET
MAD AT US FOR WANTING TO FOCUS
ON THE RIGHT ISSUES.
THAT'S -- I FEEL LIKE IF WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT CRIME, WHY ARE
WE BAD PEOPLE?
>> Michele: LISTEN, TELL HOW
HE FRAMES IT.
THIS ADDRESS HE IS SUPPOSED TO
GIVE MS. ABOUT HOW IT IS THE
SOUL OF OUR COUNTRY.
OUR RIGHTS ARE BEING TAKEN AWAY.
HE IS BASING THIS ON THE WHOLE
HOBBS DECISION.
BUT HE'S RIGHT, OUR RIGHTS ARE
BEING TAKEN AWAY.
WE ARE LOSING OUR RIGHT TO
DOMESTIC TRANQUILITY BECAUSE
THERE'S CHAOS AT THE BORDER.
WE ARE LOSING OUR RIGHT TO
SELF-DEFENSE BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO TAKE GUNS AWAY.
WE ARE LOSING OUR RIGHT TO
FREE SPEECH AND FREEDOM OF
ESPECIALLY REFINED ANOTHER THE
FBI PUT SOME PRESSURE ON
FACEBOOK TO MUTE A STORY ABOUT A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
GIRLS ARE LINEAR THEY ARE LOSING
RIGHTS TO TITLE IX TO COMPETE
AGAINST OTHER GIRLS BECAUSE THAT
CATEGORY WAS SUPPOSED TO BE FOR
THEM BUT THAT'S KIND OF BEING
LOST.
SOME OF THE RIGHTS ARE BEING
I WOULD LIKE THEM TO ADDRESS
THAT.
>> Greg: INTERESTING POINT.
I GAINED THE RIGHT TO COMPETE
AGAINST GIRLS.
FINALLY I MIGHT WIN A TROPHY.
>> Trace: IT'S INTERESTING
THAT HIS PRIME TIME SPEECH
TOMORROW NIGHT IS SET 9P.
BINGO!
>> Greg: TRACE!
>> Jamie: I WOULD'VE THOUGHT
PRIME TIME FOR BIDEN WOULD BE
LIKE 4:00 P.M.
>> Harold: WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
HIM.
THE NAME CALLING, IT'S POLITICS.
PEOPLE CALL HIM SENILE,
COMMUNIST, MARXIST, THEY
QUESTION WHETHER HE WON THE
ELECTION AND HE GOES WITH IT.
THE NUMBER OF THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN SAID.
GOOD FUN AND GOOD HUMOR AND GREG
HAVE A GREAT RELATIONSHIP.
>> Greg: WE LIVE TOGETHER NOW.
>> Harold: I DIDN'T KNOW IF
YOU WANTED TO TELL EVERYBODY.
HIS POLL NUMBERS ARE GOING UP.
ALL THE THINGS YOU'RE SAYING,
ALL THE THINGS EVERYBODY SANG,
GOT UP FROM THE HIGH 30s TO
THE MID 40s.
ABOUT WERE PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
IN SOME POINT OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
TWO AND A HALF MONTHS UNTIL
ELECTION DAY.
ELECTIONS ARE WON WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT HOW YOU WANT TO MAKE
PEOPLE'S LIVES BETTER.
IF ALL YOUR PLAN IS YOU WANT TO
INVESTIGATE, CRITICIZE, NAME
CALL, YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO DO
THAT FROM THE MINORITY.
WE WON'T BE ABLE TO GET STRONGER
FOLLOWING WANT TO DO HIS NAME
CALL.
BUT IF YOU CAN TEST WITH
THOUGHTS.
>> Greg: YOU SOUND LIKE A
REPUBLICAN.
WE'VE GOT TO MOVE ON BECAUSE WE
ARE RUNNING OUT OF TIME.
I THINK THE NAME-CALLING IS FINE
WHEN IT'S DIRECTING IT IN
INDIVIDUAL AND POWER.
YOU SHOULDN'T BE NAME-CALLING
AND ENTIRE GROUP